okay all right guys we are playing a
game called don't trust I know what
you're saying I know what you're saying
a lot of people are saying like my
parents tell me to trust well so
different
it's made with you today so we're gonna
see what's going on here okay welcome
after finishing at a server when I turn
into a starting point orders hip new
questing good luck all right objective
eat a cookie located in the kitchen shut
I'll try
hello sir our life begins after coffee
whoa
okay spider-man very nice very well boys
you're like [ __ ] okay right okay
where's their cookies okay say yeah hey
cookie look at it in the kitchen
pretty good pretty good
I received a hundred points of
experience Wow toys in the toy box
easy easy very easy okay where it's a
[ __ ] the toy box
[ __ ] sad ass toy box you see if this
toy box okay let's say hey Roy yeah
where I go okay toe box is like probably
here
oh hey Zeus out there this it's a pie
the box in his toys on it
yeah very easy
turn on a phase a easy very obey yes sir
yes sir
you see what's over this door
all right enter put the Kitsch out there
this [ __ ] fan gave me a headache
okay it's a good place for this knife
don't forget about so quiet any music
perfectly intensifies experience turn on
the radio
[Applause]
[Music]
ready go
laughs are you really worried people say
that a boy carrying boxes does the
answer me
[Music]
you've reached the bad ending [ __ ]
[ __ ] dumb is dick okay Esther's a
[ __ ] again that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
never ever want to play a game over
don't trust okay yeah yeah yeah you know
get the [ __ ] out of the way [ __ ] yeah
that's pretty good
Prager I tell ya okay good toys in the
toy box
I got you [ __ ]
I'd say let's say that I see man right
now
yeah leveled up Honeybear stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] a box doing over there
you got very mad I told you right here
honey bear honey bear Oh get in there
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hey mr. ball okay mr.
ball
I got ya my star ball let's say what's
going on I did it
I think such a get what [ __ ] off now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god now we're gonna do this again
I guess [ __ ] do this again yeah maybe
with you tonight we all know that okay
trust the game okay I'm just gonna
[ __ ] ignore everything yeah I like
that shot you hate that yeah I hate that
[ __ ] eat it no I ain't doing [ __ ] I
see your [ __ ] toy box our way out of
here
maybe have to be like a little bit
[ __ ] level not babe a [ __ ] leveled
up ain't turning that tomato that's for
sure my juice and what if I just feel
like half the items I don't do that okay
yes stupid [ __ ]
yeah yeah I dare that taking this with
me I got my knife
sike
[ __ ] psych compared cubase paris it's
late you better go to bed before I go
back yeah I was having fun they got
handbag thanks for watching guys I don't
trust
[Music]